[Music]
oh
how'd you do that
it's the minerals check this out awesome
[Music]
watch this
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
you really food inspector as far as you
know yeah
then inspect this
dad ass shots
yep oh it's good to me
infect with your mouth oh
foreign
how you doing living the dream
little citations I just gave you from
firetown I was about to send them to Mrs
cumulus then get sprayed for fungus rot
wait
tell him what you told me about your dad
and letting him down no that's personal
it's really God to me you might feel it
too her dad will be stupid so no super
disappointed in her stop it he might
even be here
what are you doing but the main thing is
if her father can't retire it will be
all Embers
looks like I'm going home early today
[Music]
usually has their head in the clouds
oh my new jacket Earth can be a little
seedy nothing weird going on here just a
little pruning water is always getting
into something
[Music]
and fire as ordered we run a little hot
this shop is dream of our family someday
it'll all be yours but we all live by
one simple rule
fix
a pipe squished me all out of shape
that's better oh
so you've never left firetown sorry
buddy elements don't mix
plus my dad would boil you alive why
doesn't anyone get to tell you what you
can do in your life come on
why do they even have these yes who
knows
remember I see a change in you
what her guy you live here it's my mom's
place we got two kids that are swimming
around here somewhere
I've been trying to fill my father's
shoes I never once asked what I wanted
to do
write this Dad those are too hot I love
hot food
[Music]
[Applause]
you see he likes it
a world of element City includes air
water Earth and Fire
cannot mix and when they clash it's
actually pretty funny
hey sorry when you make a film about
elements you are just setting yourself
up for the puns
winner winner charcoal dinner
thought bubble maybe we play The Crying
Game let me guess you try to cry we try
not to cry oh honey you won't believe
what your baby niece did today she she
smiles
oh
Catherine O'Hara how can she make crying
sounds so funny
it was really fun to record
Sarah does something really special like
how did you guys actually do this
to be able to see all the different
characters pop out at you and really
come to life oh my goodness after seeing
my character we are total twins
like looking in a mirror two two
I think putting your heart into the
story is a big ingredient to what makes
a Pixar film work I've just never been
punched before faced with beauty before
I think the only way to get close to
appreciating it is to see it on a big
screen it is fun it is funny it's just
so full of life this will just hit you
right in the feels that's what Pixar
does best
[Applause]
grip who's the baby boy
seriously
[Music]
for over 25 years we've come to the
movies for a Pixar experience oh
infinity and beyond we laugh together
snack together and escape
the places we've only dreamed of
make her laugh again
oh sorry she didn't see that and on June
16th discover Disney and Pixar's
Elemental welcome to element City
[Music]
so you've never left firetown the world
has so much to offer game on one two
three
oh check out who found the gift shop
please take all that off but I got you a
hat
okay Disney Pixar's Elemental
oh
all right
[Music]
everything
oh
sorry
I'm Wade I'm Amber
[Music]